>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IT WAS A
YEAR AGO THIS BOOK THAT A
CONSTELLATION OF LEFT WING
ACTIVIST GROUPS COOKED UP A
SERIES OF OUTLANDISH LIES
DESIGNED TO KEEP BRETT
KAVANAUGH OFF THE SUPREME
COURT.
THE NATIONAL NEWS MEDIA AS
YOU WILL REMEMBER JOINED THE
SMEAR CAMPAIGN.
THEY REPEATED AND MAGNIFIED
THE SLURS.
BUT IN THE END IT WAS TO NO
EFFECT.
DOLPHIN WAS CONFIRMED ANY
WAY.
WHY?
BECAUSE NOT A SINGLE
ALLEGATION AGAINST HIM
TURNED OUT TO BE TRUE, NOT
ONE.
AND SO THEY THEIR ONLY
LASTING EFFECT WAS TO
TRAUMATIZE BRETT KAVANAUGH'S
WIFE AND CHILDREN.
YET, THE LEFT NEVER TO THIS
DAY APOLOGIZED FOR THEIR
DISHONESTY OR THEIR PROFOUND
CRUELTY NOR DID THEY ACCEPT
DEFEAT.
THEY NEVER DO ACCEPT DEFEAT.
WHY?
BECAUSE WHEN POLITICS IS
YOUR RELIGION, ACKNOWLEDGING
REALITY LOOKS LIKE SIN AND
SO IT CONTINUES.
OVER THE WEEKEND THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" REVIVED THE
ATTACKS ON BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THE NEWSPAPER RAN A STORY
EXCERPT FROM A BOOK WRITTEN
BY TWO OF ITS REPORTERS THAT
CLAIMED THAT WHILE IN
COLLEGE FOR THAN 30 YEARS
AGO KAVANAUGH EXPOSED
HIMSELF IN EFFECT TO ANOTHER
STUDENT WHILE DRUNK AT A
PARTY.
THE FLIMSIEST KIND OF
CHARGE.
WHERE DID IT COME FROM?
IT CAME SECOND HAND FROM A
SINGLE CLASSMATE OF
KAVANAUGH'S A MAN WHO WORKED
AS LEFT WING ACTIVIST, LATER
WORKED FOR THE CLINTONS, IN
FACT OF COURSE 20 YEARS AGO
NO CREDIBLE NEWS
ORGANIZATION WOULD HAVE RUN
A STORY LIKE THAT ON THE
BASIS OF THAT SOURCING.
THE "TIMES" DIDN'T HESITATE
AND WAS PICKED UP
EVERYWHERE.
OF COURSE INSTANTLY AND
NTSB'S CABLE CHANNEL FOR
EXAMPLE THEY IMMEDIATELY
DENOUNCED BRETT KAVANAUGH AS
A GANG RAPIST.
>> I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF A
GUY WHO IS A ONE TIME
RAPIST.
I NEVER HEARD OF A GUY ONE
TIME SEXUAL ASSAULTERS.
I GREW UP WITH GUYS LIKE
THIS.
HE IS THE FIFTH GUY IN THE
GANG RAPE.
COMES IN EVERYONE ELSE
ENCOURAGES.
HE HAS BEEN COVERED HIS
ENTIRE LIFE.
>> AMAZED ME WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION OUT OF THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
QUALIFIED IN THIS COUNTRY OF
ALL RACES AND GENDERS THEY
CONSISTENTLY FIND MEN WHO
BEAT, ABUSE AND SEXUALLY
ASSAULT WOMEN.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE SAYING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT ABOUT
SOMEBODY WHEN THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT IT'S TRUE AND
A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT IT'S
NOT.
THEY DIDN'T HESITATE.
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES MEANWHILE
DEMANDED THAT KAVANAUGH BE
REMOVED BY FORCE IMMEDIATELY
FROM THE SUPREME COURT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT'S BECOME CLEAR IS
THAT HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
THE HOUSE ABSOLUTELY HAS THE
ABILITY TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> AND DO YOU BELIEVE THEN
THAT HE IS ESSENTIALLY A
SEXUAL PREDATOR OR THAT HE
WAS AT SOME POINT?
>> YEAH.
I BELIEVE -- I BELIEVE THAT
HE ENGAGED IN THE CONDUCT
THAT WAS DESCRIBED.
>> AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT
IT APPEARS AS THOUGH BRETT
KAVANAUGH LIED UNDER OATH
WHICH IS A CRIME, I THINK
THAT HE HAS DISQUALIFIED
HIMSELF FOR SERVICE ON THE
SUPREME COURT AND HE SHOULD
STEP DOWN OR HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
>> Tucker: A SEXUAL PREDATOR
WHO MUST BE IMPEACHED.
OKAY.
BUT, WAIT, HERE'S A LATE
BREAKING EDITION TO THIS
STORY.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE WOMAN
THAT THIS SUPPOSEDLY
HAPPENED TO, THE ALLEGED
VICTIM BACK AT YALE MORE
THAN 30 YEARS AGO, IT TURNS
OUT THAT PERSON HAS NO
MEMORY WHATSOEVER OF THE
INCIDENT.
HUH?
NOW THE PAPER KNEW THAT BUT
SOMEHOW NEGLECTED TO INCLUDE
IT IN THEIR ACCOUNT.
PROBABLY BECAUSE IT STRONGLY
SUGGESTS THEIR STORY IS ONCE
AGAIN A TOTAL CROCK.
YET ANOTHER LIE.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TOLD YOU
THAT AND THEY DIDN'T.
THEY ARE DISHONEST, OF
COURSE.
YOU WOULD THINK IT WOULD
SPUR THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES THE ONES WHO
CALLED FOR KAVANAUGH'S
IMPEACHMENT TO RETHINK THEIR
POSITIONS.
NEW EVIDENCE?
MAYBE THAT WOULD SHAPE THEIR
VIEW.
BUT, NO.
NOT AT ALL.
THEY SOUND EXACTLY AS THEY
DID A YEAR AGO.
REMEMBER.
THIS THERE IS NO PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE OR GUILT WHEN
YOU HAVE A NOMINEE BEFORE
YOU.
>> WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
DUTY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THESE ALLEGATIONS JUDGE
BRETT KAVANAUGH HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO COME
FORWARD WITH EVIDENCE TO
REBUT THEM.
>> KAVANAUGH WHO IS SEEKING
A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT TO
THE SUPREME COURT AND WHO I
THINK NOW BEARS THE BURDEN
OF DISPROVING THESE
ALLEGATIONS RATHER THAN
DR. FORD AND MS. RAMS.
>> TO THOSE OHIO HEARSAY
OVER AND OVER THIS ISN'T
FAIR TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
HE IS ENTITLED TO DUE
PROCESS.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRESUMPTION 6
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY?
HE IS NOT ENTITLED TO THOSE
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT ACTUALLY
SEEKING TO CONVICT HIM.
>> Tucker: WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO CONVICT HIM WE ARE TRYING
TO DESTROY HIM AND HIS
FAMILY NO.
DUE PROCESS OR PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE, FAIRNESS,
IRRELEVANT.
WHATEVER THEY TELL YOU DON'T
LET THEM TELL THAT YOU
JUSTICE HAS ANY ROLE IN
THIS, OF COURSE.
THIS IS A PURE POWER GRAB.
THE LEFT FEELS ENTITLED TO
RUN THE COUNTRY TRULY
ENTITLED TO IT AND THEY FEEL
ENTITLED TO CONTROL THE
SUPREME COURT.
THEY DON'T AND IT DRIVES
THEM CRAZY.
KAVANAUGH FRUSTRATES THEIR
POLITICAL HOPES SO ANY SMEAR
AGAINST THEM IS ACCEPTABLE
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS.
DON'T KID YOURSELF.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
DESTROYING BRETT KAVANAUGH.
HE IS ANCILLARY.
IT'S ABOUT DESTROYING THE
ENTIRE LEGITIMACY OF OUR
THIRD BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
THE JUDICIARY.
PLENTY ON THE LEFT ARE USING
THE SAGA PACKING THE COURT,
ADDING MORE JUSTICES TO MAKE
IT RELIABLY LEFT WING OR TO
CHANGE THE RULES SO THEY CAN
REMOVE ANY JUDGE THE LEFT
DOESN'T APPROVE OF.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THE THIRD BRANCH WAS MEANT
TO DO OR BE.
THE JUDICIARY WAS MEANT TO
CHANGE SLOWLY, THE COURTS
CHANGE DECADES RATHER IN
RESPONSE TO A SINGLE
ELECTION CYCLE.
THAT'S THE WAY IT WAS
DESIGNED AND FOR A REASON
AND FOR MORE THAN 200 YEARS
IT'S WORKED.
BUT TO THE MODERN LEFT IT'S
TOTALLY INTOLERABLE.
THEY ARE COMMITTED TO
REMAKING THIS COUNTRY
COMPLETELY RIGHT NOW NEWARK
NEEDS A NEW SYSTEM THEY TELL
US, ONE WITH OPEN BORDERS
AND FAR FEWER PESKY
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS.
RIGHTS LIKE THE FREEDOM TO
SPEAK CLEARLY, OUT LOUD.
THE FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION.
THE RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS.
THE FREEDOM OF RELIGION.
NO, TO CREATE THIS NEW YOU
TO BE I CAN'T OF OBEDIENT
HAPPY SURFS.
THEY HAVE TO DESTROY ALL OF
THAT TWO CENTURIES OF
PRECEDENT AND TRADITION.
MAYBE EVEN DESTROY THE
COUNTRY ITSELF.